hey a Romeo and Juliet story that kids
won't be bored in that's always awesome
[Music]
Gnomeo and Juliet so as you know from
the trailer and the title of the movie
Gnomeo and Juliet two kids family movie
cartoon take on the Romeo and Juliet
story which is always cool because when
I was in school we had to learn about
Romeo and Juliet I thought one thing
sweets head on desk and it snapped I'm
pretty sure I'm not the only one - so
they've done away with the Shakespeare
they paraphrase the whole movie you know
they talk normal mix some family and
comedic moments in there and here's a
shock it's actually pretty funny it's
funny it's entertaining it's good for
the family because right now there are
like no family movies out there trying
to think of one no tangled was a few
months ago I mean it was funny it was
cute mean there are a lot of moments
where I was like well he could have
developed that character a little more
but it's the movie for kids it really
doesn't matter kids don't care about
that put them in this movie they'll be
entertained Annie has humor that's good
for adults too couple of jokes they
actually push the line I like that
that's always awesome what I like about
Gnomeo and Juliet is a 35-millimeter
depth of field alright when you're
filming thirty five-millimeter and
you're focused on an object the objects
behind it are gonna be blurry that's
called depth of field the closer you get
to an object the fuzzier the background
gets so if you're zoomed in is something
that's about as big as say unknown the
depth of field is gonna be deeper and
the background is gonna be darker and
more fuzzy and that's what this movie
looks like so it really feels like
you're looking at these little garden
gnomes in a geeky tech way that's really
awesome and in a couple of parts they
actually make fun of what the movie is
you know whole kids take on Romeo and
Juliet and the fact that kids don't care
about Romeo and Juliet there's actually
a lot of voice talent in this movie I'm
not going to tell you who they are
because it's actually half the fun
figuring it out so for Gnomeo and Juliet
I would say it's a good time no alcohol
required I'm not so attached to the
movie and it's not so groundbreaking and
I'm gonna get it on blu-ray or something
like that but your kids will have a good
time if you're looking for a family
night out this is the movie or if you're
looking for something to entertain your
kids while you have a nice relaxing time
give your kids to the babysitter
babysitter takes the kids to Gnomeo and
Juliet you soak in the bathtub
take a nice pill and just relax either
way the movie is a nice little wind is
that a contribute to beaver fever
whatever
so the cartoons ruled 2010 and it looks
like they starting out 2011 pretty nice
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]